let's start this think of now you're
good here you're gone to something here
greetings from podcast Ville what's
happening you bad [ __ ] the
Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by zip recruiter listen
hiring is art
did you know that three out of four
employees say they having trouble fill
filling open positions they're taking
bold steps to attract talent by raising
wages and increasing benefits and even
that's not working do me a favor go to
zip recruit it's so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
rakul to get a quality candidate within
the first day and right now to try zip
recruiter for free the church family is
going to zip record calm slash church
that's zip recruited calm slash Church
take this meal the church wants to
welcome Sam Tripoli honor and a
privilege brother I love you very much I
love both you guys very much thank you
so much for having me on dude the love
is in the air yeah it is Lysol can yeah
so dude somebody said you read these are
ingredients man you could find
coronavirus in there do you know that
did you
like on the on the Lysol its dude I'm
telling you I know you're gonna think
I'm a crazy person brother there's way
more to this than anybody even
understands and I think it's way deeper
than just everybody I mean I'm being
honest with you man I think if there's
another play at work and that's my
opinion what is the other play I think
that the Chinese government and neo
liberals are trying to tank the US
economy so that they can get rid of
Donald Trump out of office and that
there's just a lot of stuff about this
that doesn't make any sense and it's
just some weird stuff and they're trying
to get everybody to stop going to work
stop I mean like you know they're always
saying like oh wall street dude are the
economy's in trouble Wall Street yeah
because they stopped production in China
and that's what they're trying to do
because Trump's been in this in this
trade war with China right now and
China's pissed they're not happy about
like Trump is trying to move all the
industry over the
India and China don't get along so
there's this whole thing that's going on
and I'm telling you dude it's not that
the corona virus doesn't exist nobody
saying that it exists it's just a little
bit stronger than the common cold that's
my honest opinion I've been studying
this stuff and that's what I'm telling
you but that's a different podcast I
don't want to get too weird and weird
people out but that's God honest truth
man is the funny thing your conspiracy
theory there's I'm not a conspiracy
theorist but I saw something I have
repeated this on this podcast I saw
something with my own eyes I'm not crazy
Sam you're not but I'm not crazy I got
problems I got problems like everybody
else but I'm not crazy I'm a little high
alert than most people you know dude you
are my alert and my drum and stuff like
that but I'm not crazy
this was first this first got the first
case that we got diagnosed with was
January 18 I had a travel the 24th and
for some particular reason I even asked
myself that Sunday when I was coming
back from Atlanta I said to myself is
this me or them more Asians than usual
today
like that Friday when I left there was a
lot of Asians yeah but that Sunday in
Atlanta when I was coming to LA it was
like watching a movie tripping on acid
he everybody seemed I'm not putting
anybody down I'm not making no racist
remarks just telling you what I saw I'm
coming back on my boy that was a heavy
asian plane you know where is it from
mana interesting well that's a hub okay
so uh-huh whatever it is it just seemed
like an overwhelming amount of Asians to
everybody else who was traveling and I
get back and they're talking about this
thing and
then it blows up you know I'm like
everybody else there was mosquitoes
there was a number two years ago
mosquitoes are gonna kill you and then
bola think what's gonna kill you and all
every election
all like this is the type of people you
know we're used to it but this was
something that it seemed like it's like
when somebody puts uh well you put you
go you you a bomb your apartment yeah
you're a bomb your apartment and you
come back and you go okay no roaches an
awesome two days later the guy next door
knocks on your door it goes is it me or
have you seen an unusual amount of
roaches lately
oh [ __ ] you know yeah oh my god by me
putting that bomb out the guy next door
Nelson lady next door knocks on your
door two days there's because it me or
my see more roaches were young I'm Roach
freak you know I got a bug in here
there's one he's laying on the cloud
upside down his legs are moving that's
it yeah that I saw that and I came back
and I'm not you know I'm not doing drugs
I'm not drinking I'm not I mean I take
an edible whatever I fly but I saw a lot
more than what I thought so in my world
if I ever was to hear this I can
actually raise my hands I gotta be
honest the week of the 25th there was an
unusual high amount of Asians traveling
that weekend like trying to get out my
everybody knew something that we didn't
know they were walking with their heads
look down fast rolling those [ __ ]
cars those [ __ ] things and I was like
okay and now I'm seeing all this [ __ ]
the cancellations you know South by
Southwest would have [ __ ] would have
thought you know and then and and this
is like this gonna be all of March dude
it's gonna be interesting how long this
gonna be all of March and I told you I
went to the Comi store the Dussehra
Melrose show again no reason to lie to
you we bump them regulars for 20 [ __ ]
years yeah
past the kitchen as soon as I walk into
the main room I smelt it my [ __ ]
spider yeah
I made that turn into the main room it
was happy
down the hallway heavy behind the stage
it was heavy when I opened up the Graham
room there was too many people in the
[ __ ] room the green room and I walked
out I was like [ __ ] this place i sat
behind by the corner where the door is
yeah we get one look i sat there the
rest in land I was ahead I ran out of
that main and it's like people are not
respecting it enough well I that's a big
thing I have to do with my show now
there's too many people hanging out and
like I'm very much into like I'm very
like when I first moved here man like I
remember being at this one comedy club
and I'm not gonna say the name of the
comics or the managers but they were all
sitting there and I could tell that the
value of my opinion was totally weighed
by what my IMDB credit was you know so
I've always been very very like cautious
on how like how I treat younger comics I
always want to show them respect because
you know you never know where they're
gonna go and I remember that I was them
when I was like sure I was gonna be this
really big name comic and like I felt
like I was getting disrespect so I
always show love man cuz at the end of
the day they're people with a dream man
and people don't realize you're laying a
lot of [ __ ] on the line to come out here
and sometimes you don't realize til it's
too late and it's almost too late to
start something else so you're kind of
trying to figure out what to do next
so I always show people up but the point
is is that it's gotten too busy back
there I have to let the comics you were
going in a show chill and not you know
because everybody want because the
Comedy Store dog is like nothing you've
ever seen before
there's no other place in the world like
you can't go to the Viper Room or the
whiskey and hang out with tulle right or
hang out with Led Zeppelin or hang out
with any bigger the Comedy Store the
[ __ ] savages they're everywhere all
your heroes are just walking down the
hall so it's a very unique place and so
but sometimes people they have you know
they don't have any of that ah social
etiquette and they're not self-aware and
they're just run in the back and you
know it's like oh well it's a 'roger and
I'll talk to Diaz well it's like their
work can do that you know you gotta give
them their space to get work and so I
totally
understand what you were talking about I
have for my show personally comedy chaos
I'm gonna start really shutting down who
can go backstage so the comics can have
a moment of peace and well no no I
wasn't mad about that I was just saying
that there was a lot of people back
there there was a lot of people back
there and with this virus
yeah you know nobody [ __ ] knows
there's no ventilation in that back it's
old-school it's old-school it's not a
window back there so you go back there
you breathe them whatever the offices
breathe yeah alright and if this is a
six-foot distance so I just played it
for what it was up listen I'm not
[ __ ] I'm not think I'm gonna die yeah
I'm gonna [ __ ] die from it or
whatever I just want you to be cautious
I'm making great [ __ ] decisions I
just saw a thing on Facebook
did you see it about the strip club in
Vegas oh [ __ ] just like hand
sanitizing they went out with hundreds
of thousands of sanitizing money you
can't touch the check now you can't you
have to believe during the epidemic
people are still getting lap dances and
they're like purling their hands and
[ __ ] you know there's no I don't want to
lap dance I want you to sit on my face
yeah I got a prob my face what lap dance
equal to my ten what am i 14 either you
gotta sit in my face and weirdest thing
is this it just bro this is gonna shut
down I am for sure
you know they put something out that NBA
games might have to be played with no
audience and the bronze said he didn't
he didn't want to play with that without
a crowd but the might have no crowds
there it's interesting em being shady is
[ __ ] though they got that they're all in
that Chinese money and [ __ ] that
affected their rage yes that affected
their ratings dude they got shut out
China for a while that affected their
ratings man when LeBron was like hey man
mind your business you'll know what's
going on over there we're like what
you're the guy that's telling us I can't
breathe and every social thing you're
putting your [ __ ] your nose into a
novel side and you're like leave the
Chinese alone dude there
a million Muslims in concentration camps
in China and nobody gives a [ __ ] right
it's so weird dude China Shadia [ __ ]
what it Muslims in concentration who
they got they just locked him down dude
they're on lockdown dude they put them
in these camps man
and these internment camps man it's
really sad and it's really scary dude
and nobody saying everything anything
cuz it's Muslim so no people are oh it's
like dude they're people man it's like
they got locked dude some gonna listen
man mmm you know a lot of this
coronavirus hittin places where there
were like riots going on Hong Kong you
know right you know this part of Italy
that's right next to France where all
these people were all riding right
nobody's riding anymore Hong Kong's been
shut down and then they on top of that
Google's helped created Chinese social
credit score's which is basically dude
they calculate what kind of human being
you are and if your credits too low you
can't get on flights you can't get on
buses you can't do all this stuff now
there's a lot another getting you dude
you get in your house they're locking
people down it's like really it's like
scary [ __ ] dude it's like some purge
stuff going on over there and that's why
I think China's trying to play a game
with us dude they don't like that
trump's trying to like even tariff so I
didn't even know there was that kind of
tariffs man but not to get too serious
but I think there's a lot more to this
when Bill Gates is like Babe Ruth
calling out his epidemics like you know
6600
600 million people dead or 6 million
people dead and he's pointing it and
he's been talking about it forever he
just happens to own the virus you know
that you know Bill Gates has a patent on
the corona virus
he owns the patent on it so basically
the patent is that if anybody comes up
there you get a percentage of the
vaccine but he owns it and the guy who's
been talking about a [ __ ] epidemic
common dude is the guy who happens just
own now dude you ready to get where dude
hit me if you take the heat if you take
the actual name of the virus it's not
corona virus it's something else and you
do the Hebrew translation of that word
do you know what that word is
Koby now here's where it gets weird dude
coby's bumped buddy in this like
lighthouse or lifeguard company owns
he's also on the board of the three
companies that own basically the the
patent on this drug on this vaccine it's
crazy dude that's have you ever heard of
gematria no okay dude this is like old
hebrew it's basically where the heap we
have you heard your mantra no you've
never heard of it it's basically based
on hebrew math and numbers with words
words equal numbers letters have letters
have a number associated dude it's dude
with Kobe's whole thing there's so much
involved with that dude so a couple
weeks oh you have a guy on the podcast
Bishop Larry caters and what was he
saying broke it down dude that this is
basically an assassination now here's
the crazy thing on Google the day that
the moment the word got out if you went
putting Kobe Bryant it would say that
his death date and say it wouldn't say
day of death it would say day of
assassination and if you google that you
could see it it said date of
assassination and basically according to
this guy they took out Co because Kobe
was suing three pharmaceutical companies
that were putting out a Black Mamba
pharmaceutical but they were putting
opiates in it to get people hooked up
and he had found out about it and he had
said he was suing them to stop it and
there's all these he was supposed to go
to court that week the week he was the
week he died he was supposed to go to
court and to deal with this stuff so you
know in uh if you look at all this like
cult stuff the number 33 is a very big
work number right have you heard that 33
but weird he died
Calabasas you know a district that is 33
it's a 33rd district in the United
States and there's all those numbers do
when they announced it on ESPN that Kobe
ad odd you look at the you look at dude
this is weird [ __ ] man if you want me
stop tell me but because and please it
dude I'll talk
- about this your your comment sections
gonna be like I'm the biggest [ __ ]
please don't hate me no no no I love all
this stuff I love that you took the time
you know somebody took the time to
research this stuff so I know what that
was going on it's very easy if you look
at like so when ESPN announces that the
death of Kobe it's during the Pro Bowl
game and if you look at the score of the
game if you break down Jomon tree it
equals Kobe dead it's crazy stop dude
and it's everything's 24 so when so the
night before
Kobe dies he's in Philadelphia LeBron
James is passing him on the all-time
scoring list dude I'm the court do you
know what I was on the court it's a very
famous Philadelphia thing but on the
court was a snake and the snake was
chopped up okay and it's basically
symbol and it's the symbol means join or
die and that was on the court when he
was there dude and it's all this crazy
stuff now have you heard the blaze no ok
the blaze so you know you have the skull
and cross the skull bones that's a very
secret society that the Ivy League
schools were started by all the old
opium families all the families who were
who were running opium started to
started the 13 Ivy League schools so
this one the Russell's started that
stall and bones tell me when to stop if
I'm boring you ok they thought the Skull
and Bones okay and they basically did
this to create a so they could give
money to get heads up on elite children
anyways blacks can't join the Skull and
Bones they're not allowed to join so
they started another group called the
blaze and the blaze of the black secret
societies do and these their whole -
their whole saying is protect the table
they can't have a seat at the table
their job is to protect the table ok and
it's all of these super elite
african-americans are all part of this
boule ok LeBron James's chest if you
look at it the tattoo is the bleh symbol
which is a black fraternity symbol which
is crazy because he didn't go to college
so it's like he's got a giant bleh
symbol on his chest he's part of the
whole secret and that's why I'm either
convinced he wasn't at Colby's thing or
he was hiding it's like some weird you
see pictures of LeBron at Kobe's saying
it looks like Bigfoot pictures you're
like I've seen clearer pictures a
Bigfoot running through the the force
and I've seen a lot of LeBron net at a
Kobe's memorial but it's all real stuff
dude it's some real stuff he got off
because and then dude he was into some
dark art [ __ ] like if you ever look at
Kobe Bryant's workout you ever here was
a famous workout you know what's called
the 666 workout okay if you look at his
children's book that didn't come out but
if you look at the children book it's a
picture of a tree with a tree below it
which is an old occult saying as above
so below all that stuff did a lot he's
his mama's symbol as a snake eating its
tail very occultic dude huge occult
stuff now are you ready
he had this life boat or life house
company Jeff Stowell who is super shady
was his partner do you know who was on
the board of that that whole thing
Jeffrey Epstein how many [ __ ] things
is Jeffrey ever seen applause dude I'm
done no no how many things keep going
out I don't care I love all this super
occult man now if you look when Kobe
died dude during it cultic holidays it
was a call it was a holiday of sacrifice
they during that during the date since
the the January 26 yeah yeah yeah I was
during that month of sacrifice in
particular virgin it's crazy
why was Kobe's allowed to fly that day
when nobody else was allowed he's his
his his pilot was super skilled all the
biggest names used his pilot why was he
allowed when all all the Pleet LAPD
helicopters were grounded everything was
grounded
except for Kobe Bryant's his helicopter
who says they were grounded because of
the fog
that's telling my kid mister that
morning I remember going wow there's a
lot of fog when I came in at 9:30 by the
time I got home I had just been
mentioned on Twitter and I couldn't find
that Yahoo yet yeah and something came
in that's exactly when I got home I got
home at 10:15 or something like that
yeah it was like a quick me and Simone
got back we got in a car and boom we
came home that's it there was no drama
there's nobody at the airport the
inventor of the helicopter that armed
cobia was in is an old Freemason
occultic it's all it's the everything
lines up it's super crazy and super sad
because I do think they often because he
was suing the pharmaceutical companies
for millions of dollars because he found
out they are putting up opiates in their
in their in their medication to get
people hooked did you ever worry about
them coming after you I'm dude I'm so
low on the totem pole there's people I
know they do way crazier stuff that mmm
that and maybe they Wilson there I don't
know I'm a dick show comic dude I'm a
late-night dick show comic who has had a
certain a little bit of success but I'm
far from on the blip of everything but I
just find it interesting I'm not trying
to change anything I just love to hear
about it dude and all the craziness but
just doesn't even stop there if you look
at Kobe's if you look at the Mamba logo
which is the which is basically bathmat
dude it also looks like a helicopter
tailspin pointing down it's crazy it's
crazy dude it's all there man and no
[ __ ] it ends it never ends but but when
you see it the listen nobody's trying to
change anything every I just don't like
getting lied to and I just love to watch
it and call it out in real time and if
listen if I was wrong all the time like
how many times have you started
something like I ain't good at this
ain't good do it no more
you quit right if I was wrong most of
the time or a quarter of the time or
half the time I wouldn't be doing this
I wouldn't be talking about this I'm
just I'm hitting at a clip that's
insanity dude I just I call out all this
stuff cuz I eat cuz you study their
patterns and it all makes sense I'm
telling you I don't even think Jeffery
up Sheen's dad dude I don't think he's
dead I think he's somewhere chilling in
the Bahamas somewhere dude they just
activated his bank account you see huh
his bank account just got activated and
the bank was like who activated his bank
account somebody activated the bank
account there's just a whole bunch of
stuff that doesn't even make any sense
you know you asked well how was Eddie a
couple weeks ago we had a month I mean
you know I've been locked up you know
and I know when people check on you I
know the suicide watch the wing the
[ __ ] rat watch don't they have a they
have stay quality where the rats go with
some protect PC protective custody
winning and then you have the Med wing
well they checked you all the time and
you're the [ __ ] jail every hour and
then after a certain amount there's gaps
after midnight a son there's two hour
gaps
maybe the guy misses a gap here and
there but not like that night nothing
like that night whatever nothing like
that that's just too much and that jail
was kinky as [ __ ] anyway I just found a
loaded gun in on ourselves and that's
what they tell you that's the [ __ ] that
suddenly decide they tell you they found
a long gun they really found eight yeah
you know that's what they tell you you
got away but when you listen to this
[ __ ] you have to assume if they found
one they finally and a pound of heroin
and you know as everything in that if
they're telling you for reasons reading
an article last week two weeks ago two
New York Times how everybody wants every
inmate wants to go to Sing Sing Sing
Sing is the maximum security prison an
hour outside of Manhattan I went there
tons of times on visitation I used to go
visit somebody there visitation and it
was like you could just they sit at
tables like this there was
no glass there was just a long table and
we would talk and I remember talking to
him one time and [ __ ] whenever like
you know whenever they whenever you hand
the kid over that kid's got a pound
Harold yeah all right they take the kid
they're like yes sit on my lap and
they're taking the heroin out of his
pocket and putting it into their pocket
you pay the GAR this small 50 you let
you go through with the heroin and boom
it goes out into the [ __ ] earth
people don't realize yeah dude
when you're in prison and you see
somebody handing off a prison kid to a
prisoner that kids got a gun he's just
making the kid Neal's kid meals ah
so when you will like this we're talking
this not so you're his father
I'm his brother and we're talking to him
and also I brought your son ah see you
boom and then the guard will finally
come over and go we come now touch the
kid he already picked the heroin out of
his pocket yeah yeah yeah I come on back
over here with the [ __ ] coronavirus
he's shaking a good job and you know I
keep the good click shut up and he ain't
having my pockets shut up don't worry
about it how about the other like
there's groups of female officers who
are just basing hope it all dude they
make likes bang - bang these like
powerful inmates it's crazy dude don't
this so much [ __ ] that goes on in the
prison an American wouldn't you a guy
likely wouldn't believe like you just
wouldn't believe what goes on inside a
prison
no it's tough I wasn't you don't wanna
you don't wanna believe you don't
remember government's doing this you
right it's crazy
you can't believe that it's so negligent
you can't believe that it goes on you
know the reason when I was reading this
article about sing-sing is they were
saying that if you go to prison the
percentage of you percentage of
recidivism is forty five percent forty
five [ __ ] percent but if you get
college educated four percent
you get some type of college education
it drops to 4% how can I drop 40%
whether so singsing as a college as
courses there so all these inmates want
to transfer this oh it's really an hour
outside the city that's why they got a
traffic as its heat makes it easier for
your relatives to come busy you don't
have to go up to angles up there you
know there's a town up there up in new
york new york state we grew up yeah
Cortland outside chorus cities up day
largest prison cities oh yeah it's just
a prison people on there like when I was
gonna shoot that movie for what Benicia
del Toro for Showtime that thing that
him he did last year
what was that series either on Showtime
but he should don't talk about a
prisoner
oh yeah the idea lady who held two dudes
in owls two dudes get out they'd offer
me like four episodes of that show but
it shot right on the Canadian border so
you couldn't even fly into Buffalo you
got to fly into Canada and drive or what
was closer like if you drove into
Buffalo like an hour drive like it's an
hour drive to [ __ ] somewhere in
nowhere so when they told me you have to
stamp there from August September 23rd
to February 5th yeah it's not gonna
happen number one they got no hotels
their birthday got up there and that's
exactly a month into Benicia pesos would
CA I bumped into his agent one day and I
go husband he show like and he goes sure
he's done no civilization town it's a
prison town yeah everything's spaced so
you you gotta that prisons shady [ __ ] to
each one the one where that [ __ ] went
down you ever see the video we're like
somebody's doing a news report yeah and
you see somebody pull up a bucket with
the drugs yeah right there on the news
report really yeah what was that jail
where they escaped
it's like I I felt like you I thought it
was near Albany but I don't think so I
think it's more
is up there there's a town I want the
sky when I lived in Boulder a little bit
of kid I didn't live with him we were
friends we sold cars together and he
told me I had no options were to do the
family business work at the prison's my
mother works at the prison my father
works at the prison my brothers and
sisters work at the prison's my parents
their brothers and sisters their father
worked at the prison
yeah you work into the prison great pay
benefits he told me once yeah that's my
cousin's doing that in Nebraska right
now he's my cousin who takes Eddie
Bravo's uh jiu-jitsu in Nebraska Omar
right he's working out of prison he's
banging some Muslim chick I don't know
how you find a Muslim chick in Nebraska
but he found her and he's like he's like
some kind of like counselor now at a
prison up there and he's like trying to
be nice everybody he's like how's your
day you only like he's like anybody he
like he's like playing games alone he's
like I'm doing great thank you for
saying something enjoy your lunch and he
just walks off yeah yeah you don't say
I'm like an old-time it comes up to me
one day go on bro say you know when I
got locked up I was upset like a week
guys to be honest after a week I was
like to st. that bad can you believe
that I'm telling you this as a man
somebody did a guide a couple weeks ago
about how we were due in jail we would
do what I did run the joint
cuz when you're funny I've thought about
I've wanted to wherever it's called
solitary I think I could do solitary and
fine why dude I'm Jason dude you won't
live in a box that's like small it's
like dude it's a box bro is someone
I got like them it wasn't that bad I
could sit here and lie to you and tell
you the first two weeks were hell
because it was the last we saw ggest
with no air and I was in the third floor
oh no stops well I'm sure he'll start
sweating when I went to but you also
have to remember that I made it through
the system in less than a month that was
unheard of that was unheard of
like you had to sit in the system like
when I got sentenced they told me that
day they're like listen you bring a
comfortable Boulder cuz you're not gonna
see canyons Tober maybe no lie didn't
care because County Jail is two for one
so it's Tuesdays for one side then so
remember I got four years right yeah so
is simple math I had no time cuz I got
four years there was a new law House
bill 1200 if it's an on the front of
friend nonviolent crime first offense
sentence gets cut in half so one from 24
from 48 to 24 right ah I did a month I
have two weeks in County that's a month
yeah so had 23 months left and you're
eligible for a halfway house at 18
months and you get put in the halfway
house at the 16 month level once you
have 18 months you're eligible rap out
you're just to wake up away from going
back up your stuff get out like your
girlfriend is on the way to visit you on
a 4-hour Drive and they'll tap you on
the shoulder and go get your stuff
you're leaving around when you're like
what am i my girlfriend's yeah okay well
that's I used to love like those lockup
shows all that stuff it's crazy to me
like you were at least living in
Colorado but let's say you went on
vacation or to do a show in Denver and
did something you could just end up in
jail somewhere where you have nothing
like nothing it's crazy ended up in jail
I spent one night in jail
I bought drugs of a hooker cuz I gotten
sober and like I was hitching and I was
like [ __ ] I need drugs dude and nobody
has drugs except I didn't know anybody
would drive in Vegas this is here in LA
way back when I was just running and
gunning and I didn't know anybody that
had drugs cause like every time you get
sober you're like dude I'm out get rid
of all the drug dealers names it no drug
dealers in my phone I think you're like
man I got I got a couple days off I got
nowhere to be
man I gotta get weird right so I'd be
like who's got drugs I see this hooker
I'm like okay bad day hookers know where
drugs are dude and she's like yeah yeah
I'll get you some drugs let me get you
some drugs I'm like I'm not sure this is
a chick to be honest with you but I
didn't even care at this point you know
it's you know she got wig on look walks
like a chick talks like a chick gotta be
a chick right Hollywood this is a
Hollywood role of the host role you know
and I see her she's like yeah look let's
do it so we go I pull and she runs in
she grabs my [ __ ] forty bucks I got 40
bucks worth and as soon as I pull up I'm
like oh man life is over dude I am done
man so they pulled me over I'm like I'm
AM dumb done I'm never gonna go to
Canada I'm just going through all this
stuff so so uh they get me out the
handcuffed me I'm like great in
Hollywood where I live for eight three
blocks of me Oh Mike I'm [ __ ] man and
he's like where's the drugs on my own I
don't know and he reaches in he pulls
out and dude I gotten I basically gotten
ran by this by this chick or whatever it
was ah for 40 bucks I got like nothing
right and I was like I didn't care at
that point cuz I just wanted running gun
right run and gun so he's like he pulls
it out he's like where's the rest of
that go man that's it and like I made a
mistake I shouldn't even you know new
rules anybody listening if you haven't
been in jail never admit to anything
they're not your friends man you know
not your friends you don't what is this
I don't know dude where'd you get this
don't know what you're talking about
don't know I didn't know that right no
nobody so I I end up so he's like he
pulls I goes where's the rest if I go
that's he goes where's the rest I go
that's it he goes how much
did you pay for this and I go for tea
and he looked at it he started laughing
and then the chick would just [ __ ]
jacked me started laughing everyone's
laughing cuz I basically untaken for the
40 that I paid for like the nothing the
nothing of drugs I bought right so then
I go to jail and it's my only night I
ever stayed in jail LA County no West
Hollywood right bye owe me but yeah no
no no no no down in Boys Town man I
don't know why they took me there
because it was way down the other way
but they took me the way to the West
Hollywood sheriff's Jail
okay and dude I don't know what it is
but dude if they know it's your first
time in jail only they they try to run
some [ __ ] on you do they put this
homeless student but in two SEC's shits
his pants dude they pulled him out said
another one in shits his pants dude
they're Jews so I'm trying you know so I
don't know what I'm getting charged with
so I like their do my and this is the
time I had a super like Armenian mohawk
and it's like I'm like what am I getting
charged when he's like felony possession
I'm like and I just started I'm like oh
man I'm never gonna travel anywhere to
do stand-up and and to this day so like
I've been doing this Armenian benefit
for like 20 years man it's the Armenian
bone marrow registry right ah
and the and on the board is Geragos the
lawyer and like dude I mean I'm broke at
this time dude like I got no money man
and I'm like [ __ ] man I'm gonna call
this dude and just see if I can do a
Hail Mary pass so I call him up I'm like
hey he's like what's up Sammy I go hey
man I made some bad decisions and I need
some legal thing and he's like well okay
what do you got how much cash you got
I'm like I'm hurting he's like okay just
come down so it comes out he goes here
I'm gonna charge you 1,500 I'm gonna
represent you and they set me down and I
so I'm we're going to this trial right
dude the police so they do I forget what
the what it's called but they basically
say they want to all the records on the
cop that arrest me right I've I don't
know what the word is but they call it
so I said
another trial I show up with my lawyer
and dude the the police union rep shows
up and goes we're not going to give our
records on this on this cop and we want
the charges dropped and the charges got
dropped because this dude was dirty so
and dude and like if I hadn't done this
charity event got a lawyer that knew how
to run this game I would have been asked
man but I got out of it cuz I did
charity work and I never had to end it I
never messed that [ __ ] again dude but
did I mean like that's the system man
poor people get [ __ ] do ya [ __ ] dude
that is the worst when you see those
lights go you're like oh man you think
your mom's gonna find out you're like
hey you get arrested I'd learned it the
hard way I was I'm not a cheap person
but nobody wants to pay for a lawyer
nobody wants to pay for a boy and I'll
never forget getting arrested getting
heat the the the other guy got arrested
first so he had a private defendant that
means you can't have a private defender
because it's good conflict of interest
so they had to get me a court-appointed
lawyer who was horrible he was horrible
he was horrible
but I ran with it I'm like maybe let's
see what happens and my friend and I had
a guy called everybody told me to call
this one guy I called to him and he
wasn't a friend of mine but we became
friends over time and he sat me down the
first thing he says you better open your
piggy back I just started put money in
that big that piggy bank has been empty
for two years and now I get broke my
heart oh yeah like I gotta open it and
he's like you gotta open it how much
goes well how much do you want to stay
out
how much do you want your freedom yeah
you know so I had to take everything I
had you know I kept the attorney I had
until I could find the betel nut but the
best thing I did was my friend
recommended to me with a law clerk of
the Dean of the law school he goes trust
me when I got in trouble when the mine
told me to go meet with him he'll
simplify it for you
a long conversation I think the guy want
like three grand
oh man half hours man that is fresh too
and I was like broke but I go you know
what I'm gonna cancel it I'm not gonna
pay him can we fight on you know
whatever
I'm gonna call my mother's attorney Sam
DeLuca this guy was a savage you ready
for this yeah I call him my same thing
you did Joey Diaz system or a son ba ba
ba he goes all right because I want 30
just to get on the plane it was 1987
guys and this guy just won a 30 30 grand
30 grand oh my god just to go on the
planet so I knew already I like that I
was like let me call you back in the
club yeah I was like dirty grand just
for a plane ride what am I gonna do
about this trial what am I gonna do once
I'd like to see the law clerk told me
exactly what to do the steps do you know
goes I would take your case but as soon
as I walk in there with here they're
gonna give you ten years you're in the
lamp what are you doing you're alone
doing love because you bring some
[ __ ] shoe a tiny enhance like they
not throw the book at you
they don't want to see us licked you in
here they don't want to see like a slick
white guy you got a higher a guy that
mirrors them this guy told me that at
the time they had a law school Spanish
so he like we got
interesting me and he's like you want to
go to law school when we [ __ ] he's
like I'll hook you up
I'm putting the CEOP program I mean oh
my god it was crazy a felon that Spanish
will accept you and all this [ __ ] so he
broke it down from he goes this is
listen you could pay all the money in
the world you're still going to do
ninety days there's no judge that's not
gonna sentence you 90 days yours I don't
care who you walk in there you're doing
at least 90 days I go what about
work-release he goes whoa I don't think
so because that's gonna be [ __ ] tight
and I got he gave me a short list of
guys and I had to meet with all of them
and I can't tell you the number my guy
wanted he wanted it up piss off
peace first upfront and then he wanted
her back end oh my god I had to give it
to him
oh my god this white boy went to work
Jack the back end of what you have to
give them up front and a back end
yeah but the back ends like when the
movie there's more to get poison this is
what you're given
it's what you're given so it's ten just
to open up the conversation and I'll let
you know when that runs up yeah I'll let
you I'll let you know when the ten runs
out and then it was like I was on
retainer for a month so from January
February of 87 til from December of 87
not from January of 87 to August on 87 I
think I had to give them two grand a
month but something like that calls
paperwork and then I got hip to the
thing those calls were costing me $200
yeah so I didn't call the worst did not
call I would not call and I could see my
bill went down on my roof cuz every time
I call them I'd [ __ ] complain about
some I just saw a bell across the street
on here 250 250 250
but this guy was good he got the job
done for me he got me hey man you pay
for what you get explained it to me get
what you pay for install me the steps
what he was going to do like I met with
him and then a week later I met with him
again he turned the sheet of paper
around he handed to me he goes these are
the steps and he hooked me up with a
private investigator to counter private
investigate counter everything that
[ __ ] charged me an arm and a leg
that was miserable oh it was miserable
but that and then the divorce don't even
get me started
ha ha ha ha my divorce was easily 2 1 it
has oh my and 160 that winning credit
cards and half of that I paid and
happened I didn't I just ripped up the
card give me a bad credit school it was
horrible it was a horrible experience
the whole legal system whole ridiculous
timbale it's so bad now I know how to
narrow it down like now I got everything
ready I know ideas do you know that I am
like 17 and 3 and traffic Corp though
are you yeah dude I represent myself all
the time and you beat him dude I be I
beat a red-light camera one time dude I
beat this dude I fight it tooth and nail
I show up in a suit i cross-examine the
cops man I one time what's the call when
you call in a witness i subpoenaed my
girlfriend one time i subpoenaed her to
come in and as a witness i
cross-examined her i lit these cops up
dawg I set him up I get him going one
way in that boom I prove they're liars
dude and the judges get so pissed man
they get so pissed man one chick was
like okay sit down and then she went the
whole day with all of her cases she went
the whole day and then she pulled me up
at the end and she's basically like dude
I want to find you guilty cuz you're an
[ __ ] okay but I'm gonna let you go
because in the eyes justice you weren't
you didn't break the law you did what
you had to do and I cross do this cop
state the whole time just mean-mugging
me like watch him
was gonna happen cuz I lit him up dude I
set him up I'm like how's traffic going
I went to the board which had all the
intersections and I go explained traffic
was a free-flowing wasn't free-flowing I
took pictures of it so I caught him line
on that part dude always the only time I
didn't win it in a cross-examination was
when the cop lied they're cops
straight-up lie and I and I lost I okay
man well you know what I can't I can't
win if you're not going to tell the
truth that's it dude seventeen and three
traffic tickets dude because I used to
have a red car and they'd pull that
thing over all the time really yeah dude
red cars get pulled over all the time
but I didn't know if you had a all the
time
dude that's why I hear black people
complain about cops I'm like dude have
you been pulled over 20 times cuz I have
oh dude I used to do a joke about I get
like a 300 hour ticket and thank the
cops you ever done that you're like it's
three to take you're like thank you you
like dude that's like you think thank
you if you got prison rape dude worse
ticket I ever got was September 14th
2000 three days after 9/11 three days
after 9/11 you ready for this one I made
a left turn Oh curse on you know what
curse on it yeah yeah yeah you ain't
gonna believe this this could only
happen uncle Joey where were you on
Santa Monica or I was on I was on how
Sunset Boulevard I made a left on curse
on ya hold into the 7-eleven yeah yeah
yeah holdin legit the whole thing yeah
I'm sitting exact who are you talkin
what happened was a car left his tires
like there was four cars yeah so there's
three four and this is the handicapped
spot so this guy parked here this guy
parked in this Lane this guy parked here
this guy parked here and my car was on
the handicapped spot
oh that's the world standing in front of
7-eleven and I saw the cop go by and
actually make a u-turn and pulled in and
got out of his car and so those cars
you're mine he goes on making your
license registration I go
the car's not stolen because I didn't
say that
no worse do four hundred and fifty
dollar ticket did handicap Jesus call
the cops I'm soon he was parked in oh no
no no yes so I think I did something did
something creepy I got out of it I gotta
take a picture or something like I took
pictures something happened where I was
like bro look at the cars that the
parking handicapped parking is still
it's still open or something like that
you know I was with ran yeah cuz we all
lived by curse on we all live little
Ralphie yeah yeah yeah yeah so the guy I
was with lived in Ralphie's building and
he went over and got a camera ran back
while the cop was giving me the ticket
and took the pictures and then I took at
the court and beat him yeah I do
one time I was driving down [ __ ]
Street it's got a post office on it by
Hollywood also there's a cellar level on
that corner down the corner was that bar
he used to serve the [ __ ] it doesn't
matter Sacred Heart School yes you know
what's a good heart yeah is the back
yeah blows - yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah on that block they're supposed to
all fist is a school there's something
else on that block one am going on that
block right to go to gaol I'm going to
gouge studios okay I make it right I
stopped at the stop line my phone rings
I swear to God I looked down at the
phone like this and when I look up a
motorcycle cop comes right across and he
goes pull over and he gave me a ticket
for being on the phone ago unbelievable
because I just saw you look at I looked
at it because my friend called but I
didn't pick it up it still he gave me a
ticket that was the worst on all the
tickets because I went down there
I tried to argue it they said no but
they were like come in listen just pay
the fine but that that's not what pissed
me off I had to do like this traffic
school yeah like one point and then they
took it they took the point back when my
license is clean well piss me off the
most about this at that time was I
didn't have a California license do you
know that yeah I had a Colorado license
I never decided to switch it and never
switch to Lola who cares about me
yeah I wasn't paying know nothing about
nothing I went down there and when I
went down and they said okay mr. Diaz
guilty but whatever [ __ ] it basically
told me that's that's what I pleaded to
they're not having a ticket a license oh
yeah they would say bring the license
and it gets taken off 200 it pretty much
told me that I was I take the 320 yeah
taking my driving test never see you
guys again no I came to 325 I was first
off they go do you have you been the
Koala yeah yeah yeah
first of they go who speak Spanish and
who does it half the [ __ ] court gets
up and they put you on the other side
have you been through this yeah dude
people show up in their pajamas I'll be
crazy do people just like [ __ ] for I've
been court in New York Colorado New
Jersey I've never seen court crazy like
California dude Long Beach you ever been
a long beach court dude that's shady
[ __ ] chicks with [ __ ] neck tattoos
looking like they're about to shank
somebody for child support it's shady a
[ __ ] up in Long Beach Long Beach is the
best city
it's like La adjacent like the real
people like real audience you played the
long beach laughs actor ton of fun man
but that Court is shady a [ __ ] dude
Shadia [ __ ] prison tats face tats
up to no good listen you don't want to
be in prison today no way dude it's not
we're not enough today it's not a good
well I won't like I locked up was 30
years ago
that's a complete people were smoking
still you could weigh your own clothes
inside you know HIV was the break that
you know that was the biggest fear
inside that I could if people want me to
tell you that it was like them I wasn't
at all it wasn't at all sad like I said
I was unhappy for two weeks because I
was what do you call that when you get
enough powder
oh you're you're yeah yeah detoxing
toxin I was detoxing in their first two
weeks I'd never you know I'm a smoking
dope since 78 yeah it was 88 back when
it's clean don't you it was set it was
888 and I want cold turkey you know I've
been doing powder since 79 straight
there was never like the biggest fear I
had about getting locked up was stopping
to do Lutz
that was the biggest fear I had as far
as physical fear and that stuff I had no
fear at all now it's got fat and all in
it dude it's got all sorts so you don't
know what you're snorting dude drug
dealers have to be the worst business
people ever right because they're the
only ones who sell their customers crap
it like wound your business model like
they're never gonna come back to you
dude and I was fat and all stuff so dude
what's really crazy is back in the Obama
administration Obama gave the Long Beach
port to China just gave it to China
China was running a long beach port and
that's where all the [ __ ] was coming
through dude and that as much as people
hate Donald Trump one of the good things
that he did is he took that port back he
goes aha you ain't run this port no more
this is American port we're running the
port now a lot of dark stuff was coming
coming through that Long Beach port in
particular
fentanyl fentanyl was like made at MIT
some Chinese do grab it took it back to
China and they've been shipping it over
here because that is their up
they're counter to the British India
opium wars of the long time go you know
why in China if you get caught drug
dealing it's the death penalty because
of the opium wars because back in the
day these liked these British families
were just like getting the whole entire
population of of China hooked on heroin
and then the the Emperor at one point
made it illegal to sell drugs and it was
a giant war and that's it and dude I
mean dude if you knew all the stuff that
we did to get opium man Vietnam was not
about communism it was about the Golden
Triangle - they're their opium fields
and that's the same thing Afghanistan
was about the Taliban were burning down
the opium fields and these these
pharmaceutical companies couldn't have
that so we had to go in the war man why
did we go into Afghanistan when it was
19 Saudi Arabians because we had to take
control of those opium fields and you
can see pictures of military people
guarding those opium fields and you
could say whatever you want about Trump
again he's trying to get the hell out I
have kin of Stan dude that is just
sucking our money up man trying to get
out of there so he makes these deals
with the Taliban just let us get out
don't attack us and when you put that
clause in there of course somebody's
gonna attack and it's not probably gonna
be a Taliban why do they want to attack
us when they want us gone we're we're
saying we're leaving
why are you tagging it it's not them
it's people don't rent it I thought Iran
was an Achilles because we we we killed
that who's you I hear some crazy [ __ ]
dude there's a belief that Iran and
Trump work together to take out that
Solomon because that Solomon was getting
too powerful he's getting too popular
and too powerful so they set him up and
in Trump did it did a favor to Iran by
taking that dude out and that kind of
stopped World War three I'm telling you
man I listen dude I am of no party
brother I'm on the party of humanity I'm
all about people but there's something
Trump is a different than the other
dudes and I don't know what is I'm not
saying he's a good guy I think he's a
crime boss and it said there's no good
guys as bad they're just
I'm bosses and his crime organization is
taking over Washington DC and he kicked
out this other cabal like the George
Bush cabal which was George Bush
Clintons and the Obamas kicking them out
and they want back in because they want
the purse strings and I think that's
really what's going on here Trump isn't
Trump I'm not saying Trump's a great guy
he does some shady [ __ ] man but you know
like moat and tell me if I'm wrong but
most crime bosses want a clean
neighborhood right
they run crime but they want
organization they want clean they want
business to be done and they don't want
anyone to disrupt that that's why I
think Trump is and he's gonna he's
banging with this Hillary who's a shady
[ __ ] [ __ ] man how's this [ __ ]
kin like docu-series and podcast like
she she's like a comic dude she's
getting all this [ __ ] like she doing a
pot who's gonna listen to Hillary
Clinton podcast a lot of people i dude
and please let me know if you do so I
can block you out of my life a lot of
people more people that will listen to
you and me bro no I can't believe that
we got Stockholm Syndrome in this
country we're living in my communism we
don't even see it we don't even see it
and that's the difference between US and
Russia they know they're under that they
know they're under it we a class I am
what the I want the comment is important
them all with my wife what a couple date
nights ago what the climate is important
number one with my wife Starbucks and I
went to Starbucks went to dinner
it was date man it took out the dinner
went well it's not much get it call me
let's go get a call
running out of coffee and we're in
Starbucks and we were dealing with
possibly the dumbest persecutes again
Dom dude the dumbest person I have a man
man I ever so he would yell the coffee
before he would start making it so I'm
sitting there with my wife waiting for
my coffins a Joey flat white I'm I get
up and I go where's the coffee coz I
almost start making it why did you yell
my name you never say my wife looked at
me like just I wasn't even mad I said
something to her like don't even get
don't take it personal don't even take
it personal
they just make the visa smile coming
later yeah they're try living in mild
communism if you don't know that you're
out of your mind
between the cameras the phones the lines
that make a stand then on purpose you
know why five hours the vote when does
that ever happen in your life dude
that's mild communist that's mild
communist yeah
that's why I don't like when you go to
Austin yeah we have to eat the barbeque
lion standing on line yeah I'm with you
dude about Samuel alive I'll ever do
lines that I'm not paid for me outside
of cocaine lines I never did line we
leave them
I don't do lots I don't get it I'm a
driver we got to do a line that ain't
gonna happen
yeah I dude I don't stand on line the
taco can't be that good you ever walked
it and drive down like sunset or
Hollywood and you see this line out this
out this nightclub and it's all these
hot chicks and then wait why are you
waiting in line you're why people are
going to the club you can go hang out
and hang out a laundry mat at that place
will be jumping if there's a bunch of
hot chicks in like miniskirt I don't get
I don't want get and saying it's like
it's like 12:30 and night the bars close
of the last calls at 1:30 and you're
still waiting in line like what are you
doing what about the people that wait in
line for breakfast at this guy
I'll fight ever do it a crawl right on
what say my play just kill the people
still waiting on line on sunset last
time I had to go for blood test I drove
by there and that was like my sunset oh
yeah
weird Mexican high school kids go before
in and out food I mean dude it's I liked
our house you names how about the hot
dog place man it's a great hot dog but
you see people like and line out the
door I know I don't want to say the name
but it's like you're the pynx man it's a
great hot
that's a terrible hot dog that's the
worst hot dog you'll ever eat your life
I went there one time in 98 and threw it
away like the one time I had a Taco Bell
commercial yeah honey and I took like me
was like
me and told my buddies going down and I
was like and that white kids there who
from Idaho was some [ __ ] they're reading
stuff I'm like how can you eat this AHA
the bun was terrible the dog is dry
everything I mean the food the fries are
bad everything was bad everything was
bad then when it is good
you walk out like I'm in where there was
a place on Hollywood Boulevard that
cooked the hot dogs and beer and they
gave that big french fries with this
cream all we they had like bigger fries
the most you know la have yeah yeah he
fries yeah I roll McDonald fries this
place had a steak fry but just a little
smaller and they will cut with a knife
and big and they were fresh he throw him
right in and funny you know like cook
them and then he give you like this
little sauce and you dip the french
fries in while you were eating a hot dog
and they got fresh-squeezed lemonade ah
but the combo is $12 I didn't know if
that I left that to my wife is that it's
a good hot dog but we spent yeah
$42 oh my dear it's ridiculous you know
what you're making a good point
we are spent that's crazy I can get 20
hunt down the seaside I get 20 hot they
are 20 bucks for 40 bucks like I think
there was a place I went to Seaside Park
one time last time I was assis my part
there was a guy on the corner I gave you
10 hotdogs for 20 hours
I bought them all and I ate them all
right there can't be the hot dog head of
them nice and hot dogs for these
[ __ ] don't know did this town
they just make up numbers see what will
pay they don't know they don't know so
it just doesn't matter at all Sammy
trips man you've come along with your
father now
yeah I'm a dad shout out to the mother
of the children Martha she want me to
say nice things she's like you better
say nice things about me I'm like I have
nothing but love for you and I
appreciate the field trip I love it it's
it's a giant change in my life and it's
the best blessing ever and when people
say that
what do you don't kid you hear people
say that you're like whatever no it
really is it has allowed me to change
the way I operate and I work smart not
hard now I have to work smart I mean I'm
always hustle but now I have to pick and
choose where I hustle how I hustle and
it's a blessing dude and we got a nice
little house and you know the baby's
mama the mother of the child is a
wonderful person Martha and she's it's
great dude I love my kids ghosts a ninja
dude goes to ninja how old are they no
they are one month two days how does it
feel to you walking around this feel
like you're walking on I just float and
do it now there's a couple moments when
they're crying and you wanna go to sleep
but even then it's like it's impossible
to get mad at them you know you're just
like okay okay okay you just and you
know there's times I ain't get you get
no sleep when people tell you no sleep
it's no sleep do those babies but now
we're starting to enter a nice little
pace or sleeping along or like dude like
one recently I got four hours man that's
some Terri Schiavo [ __ ] right there they
all love it dude they all love it come
on they're coming to visit yeah they you
know they have they have to get off from
work but they're all come and my
brother's super excited my brother will
run strip bars my brother flip strip
bars and he's like now that I have
nieces I kind of don't want to be here
anymore and so he's gonna come out we're
very excited
Martha's mom came out she's wonderful
Stan's wonderful and you know for every
one kid you have to have to an extra
adult so if you have one kid you have
two adults if you have two kids you need
three adults so you got to have like a
rotation eight-hour shifts man just to
get done but they're great the moms just
pumping milk she's a milk machine milk
machine gallons Sammi Jesus what did you
do to deserve this I don't even know do
cuz she does have twins and her family
now have twins in my feels like I said
yeah I always know they're gonna have
girls why would God give you an I meet
you rogon like there's a whole bunch of
people with girls and you have to change
you have to change the way you think
change the way you act as you could tell
look all my bosses
he told me tonight if she was coming
here I'm coming at you no dude your kid
wants the beautiful clothes and this is
what you need to do I took it to the
movies this morning like the good to see
I took at the ice skating you know and
it's so weird how
I still remember me getting I can
honestly say this I still remember
calling Ralphie and going what's the
story we're getting a high or one he's
like man I'm over here with the kids I
have to see you lay them me hanging up
like what a fool you know and now I feel
like I owe them an apology because it's
like I can't even explain to you I love
when people hit me up hey come to the
Westside I got a podcast to do you're in
no danger
that's an hour yeah oh yeah dude that's
an hour and then I'm gonna be there for
10 minutes 20 and that's another I want
a half then I got to drive back the ow I
got till 2:30 yeah I got told to tear
yeah so I really can't
that's three hours you're in Burbank
Elysian Park is the farthest I'll go for
a podcast you know maybe Tom Segura up
here and the other guy right crusher no
the other guy he was just here Ziggler
Ziggler oh sick blurs cuz they're close
by yeah yeah yeah I can't go to Marina
del Rey for you park
I love the valley by the way I was a
Hollywood forever I love the value in
the valley man yeah dude Valley Village
brother okay so you're hop skip and
Chuck I love it man don't get my first
move from Hollywood I told my wife don't
expect me to do anything up here I'm at
the first two lights a clean sweep cuz
it was so quiet it was like completely
different than I was used to the noise
and the yelling and screaming in
Hollywood all night I lived right there
on Schrader you know that's what it was
dead it was cracked then yeah when I
moved in there and the quality was
selling crack 98 it was selling crack on
all those streets by the Mann's Chinese
Theater
oh yeah do is walk down that's orange
yeah we gotta do is walk to Selma yeah
dude Selma if
you just walked off Hollywood Boulevard
by the by the man Chinese need a walk
down a block they'd be three guys there
selling crack
I smoked crack with that guy that silver
robot guy I smoked crack six weeks
yeah dude the whole time you smoked
crack all your thing is like [ __ ] I'm
smoking crack dude I'm a little bit it's
the words daily commit I did not commit
it that started because I used to drive
on that Street and I would see those
streets and finally one night I said bro
what's up and he goes what's up what's
up what's up I don't know what's up you
holding what he got 20 yeah took a 20
home with me number like this how naive
I was to crack I cut it and I snorted it
and I'm like nothing happened
it's not like cheese and I told my
friend the next day I won't overcook
like Molly was that's not really so I
went over there again the next day and
bought some more on this time oh man
six weeks hours hooked line and sinker I
would go home get a can of coke and D it
dry that would blow dry and then make a
little hole and use the light that would
good odds is cracked out you know the
crack dealer hates the math dealer dude
crack dealers hate when you discover
math that's what's so tell me you guys I
go to these meetings on time here these
sites like crack chiller hates meth
dealer dude did crack until I ran out of
it in El Paso
I went del paso a week and there was not
gonna get crack gonna get the real stuff
yeah god it was everywhere real stuff is
everywhere haha so but nobody was
cracking up no I don't have to crack
that up with a microwave oven I know
exactly how it might crack it up oh
really yeah three fingers of water
coffee cup coffee cup three fingers of
water a gram
powder - what do you just pour the
powder right in right in you pour the
baking soda in first two tenths of
baking soda and then a gram of powder
putting the microwave oven for 20
seconds you take it out you pour it
upside down I'll get a black
handkerchief that's a little rock cuddle
up you take those little rocks don't cut
them up dude and you roll it in the
number oh dude or you take that you put
in your cigarette you just put it right
outside and you end up like that black
dude that got beat up in New York did
you see that now what did I do
I don't I do get that you see that video
now the poor black guy couple weeks ago
got beat up on a number the cops came
and they asked him what it was gonna
become detective held them and awesome
oh yeah yeah yeah he cop cars flying by
awesome poor black guy you couldn't do
none next thing he had eight cops on
table well that dude got beat ended up
getting beat up yeah but what did he
actually do smoke the joint in New York
unbelievable man held him like he was a
gangster like he had killed eight kids
you took the guy killed eight kids the
cops ran up to him like when these cops
study who raised these cops I've got a
becomes my family dude you know it's
just like I have cops in my family also
but there's a limit yeah it's common
sense dude and I walk past you and I
smell pot I'm looking keep walking I'm
like the cop in the town and when they
got out with the machine guns and the
cop was in a construction site and he's
seen him
and he just turned his head like I
didn't see nothing that's me he's mine
you [ __ ]
yeah it's marijuana whether it's legal
it's not legal look at sure look at your
job description see if you have time
Deonte I was in Hollywood without work
oh yeah that was in Joe's pizza yeah man
I went to Joe's pizza on the way home I
loved Joe's pizza hey dude I was at
Joe's pizza they show me a picture of
you you were just there and then we went
in and we got pizza to this last week
yeah dude
yeah I got the the grandma it's the best
pizza dude got a 12 o'clock when you
leaving the store I can eat that oh I
live that's my Tuesday yeah that's my
Tuesday all day I get up Tuesday morning
Inbox
I love it Krav Maga brother shout out to
the Jews dude I do that Jew fighting dog
I could I go I go to boxing class on
Tuesdays
that's why Tuesday's my longest day it
starts at 9:00
Podcast in the afternoon I test the
earth war then two shows on a Tuesday Oh
Mike I gotta listen to her podcast I
don't love we just keep it on we keep to
ourselves until she gets that thing but
she's good now so you really good she's
going pages it's three pages every week
it's a different animal a couple weeks
ago we did an experiment with oxygen we
do a little experiment oh that's so cool
man
I give it 10 bucks a week she gets 40 a
month Mario pockets have more than half
the people making us put 20 in the bank
and keep 20 that's great dude today
yesterday she went to the book farm and
she bought her own books or whatever she
bought her own books and then she had 6
bucks left my wife is like you wanna buy
any more books they nope save this cash
yeah so you want to buy a book really
yes they don't at all but it's uh it's
really weird when you have a child and
you and people don't really get it and I
don't have time you know people just
call me like what can we do lunch
because it's not possible to we don't do
lunch we do lunch on the move cause I'm
moving I know I gotta go over there oh
you know what I had time and I remember
to call you but what I'm moving out
time for lunch who has time for lunch I
got time to meet you in Burbank for a
steak for lunch I don't know what time
baby hungry I lunch when it's accorded
yeah I need lunch today hey breakfast
I haven't even lunch today well it's
accordingly when you have it when you've
got a chance you know you wanna if you
wanna meet me for breakfast and you have
an ember
hope like your business amble oh yeah I
do like this is a plan to make money
I'll meet you and then you got to bring
some widget you can't just leave it at
home
no she come to the meeting with you and
I'll take the get my day starts I got
from 9:00 to 2:30 and I got a write
night I got a put back on I will go over
there so somewhere in there I gotta
write you think of four days I got doing
hours some type of work out
I got a cry oh I gotta do sup there's
nothing so you I mean you're talking
writing jokes and stuff like that you
sit down right yeah I go to coffee shop
bring the computer and a notebook so I'm
writing the one-man show looking at the
book and I'm writing jokes at the same
time you know I'm saying yeah and then I
have a section for jokes and I cleaned
them out clean them out put this with
this you know I have two specials I have
two it's a material right now and I just
borrowed jokes from each hour it's like
I have two hours and I just gotta mingle
jokes every night I don't have a special
you know what am I gonna do so I gotta
put a CD out pretty soon that's know
makes you special shoot your own special
in the mood and for what for what what
is the value of especially yeah dude
I've been thinking about that too what
is the value of a special we've kind of
gotten into this arms race thing yeah
we've gotten out of control it's to the
point where you can't wait to shoot a
special but you know what you're not
prepared to shoot a special okay it's
like every two years two and a half
years there's still of these people
doing they're doing it and I wish them
well and I'm happy for them I might just
pile half an hour dude I'm gonna put out
a 20 minute one dude there's nothing
that's what dude Richard probably put
out half an hour's I love Rogen but I
think he's got a saw like in his arms
race cuz he works at a different level
man and like my friend Sam er L he just
put out special on Comedy Central
nobody he you know he couldn't get any
offers Comedy Central put out for him a
million views a million people watch it
god bless that man dude but he I text
him like congratulations like yeah I
know I'm just worried about the next one
I'm like worried about the next dude
enjoy this victory brother that's what
the problem is we have gotten out of
what comedy dude it's just his arms race
I gotta tell you something honest to god
I'm happy yeah I'm sorry that some
people have to lose their lives yeah you
know I'm gonna have to fly I could risk
it I'm an older guy
I have pre-existing conditions you know
I smoked the last 30 years yeah 22 bong
hits a day but something needed to stop
this thing
slow it down enjoy slow it down enjoy
somewhere we lost what this was all
about we're out lost we really did lose
we're outlaws dude dude if I want to I
got a comment I got in the economy so I
didn't do to 9:00 to 5:00 nobody told me
I was gonna have a 24/7 yeah breathe
brother I'm done like anybody who knows
me knows I've been done for about six
months I've been just waiting just
breathe breathing you know when I tell
my cuz my aids don't tell me what I
don't want to do I tell them what I want
to do you know I see a purpose for a lot
of things but I don't see a purpose for
a lot of things in comedy we all forgot
what we got into this for it's just
gotten you know mean after I shot the
Netflix special it all [ __ ] came to
me everything lit see sure said to me
all those mites not used to host all
those little things she said to me it
all got clarified and that's why I built
a tan for the last two I don't listen to
no money I don't want to know what you
do this is not the way we were doing it
when I moved here only you're doing it
this way and guess what you're making a
lot of money but you're wrong because
you're forgetting this isn't a [ __ ]
race so I'm the rails now this is a
marathon why are you doing all this
right now
item eight what happens when this slows
down what are you gonna do it is so much
money man and it's like what's enough
it's it's
that guide the wolf of wallstreet agree
there's no good is good I agreed you
know I'm kind of happy except for the
debts I'm kind of happy what this I'm my
father this is cause slow it down slow
it down I know I'm done I'm done
stay home watch Netflix you know look at
my thing my flyer it's just called Tour
cool
I just want do spots that's what
television six is slinging dick is over
like the this couple venues I have that
still have the poster up they still
using it because the agents don't send
up a new stuff and stuff like that it's
just it just me doing spots and guess
what I'm gonna be the best I can be new
material from the last time you saw me
I'm not gonna Ram it down your throat
afterwards do we take pictures now I
mean I don't know we could do any more
can't now you don't want to take a
picture with nobody now you know what
who the [ __ ] would want a I don't want
to take a picture with a fat [ __ ] that's
in his mid-50s it just flew
five-and-a-half hours on a plane huh
you're the last guy somebody came up
with asti at night and while we're
talking she goes I just went to
Disneyland ask my wife right in front of
I went and got the lights off right in
front of her I wasn't got priceless
she's like oh my god I feel so offended
like I'm sorry you went to Disneyland
knowing and you work with kids you and
the you and the business of putting kids
at risk because you wanted to go to
Disneyland I don't want to talk to
nobody who's going to Disneyland right
now if somebody tells me I just went to
a concert out out I don't want you in my
house I don't want you nowhere close to
me seriously I don't even want to be out
you will not see me for weeks you will
not see me for weeks I've got those
dates I'll take them if the if whatever
if you know you're allowed to but if
they're long I doubt I'm gonna plan
until we get this thing to it until we
get something on this I don't care if
it's Chinese putting the Whammy on it I
don't care if it's Iran Japan
Cuba Ranjith no matter who the hell is
you won't see Uncle Joe now right that
dude no you're not gonna see me so so
you did the the one you did the show on
the tenth that the comma style is your
next year x1 is the 24th 24th want to
short the ass to 24 shady who knows man
I'm trying to put together the best
lineups no but it doesn't matter I don't
need like to have quotas or weaponized
diversity
I just want killers to kill it's all
about killing kill you're like my you
don't have like diversity we don't we
don't need I don't give a [ __ ] dude I
don't do I don't do a lot of time
because it's all about just keeping the
Train on the track and just letting
people a great show
let the killers killers show why bring
in for killers if you're gonna go up 10
to 20 minutes I mean it shows the run
late and then I gotta get in the car
well I think I don't do 10:30 shows yeah
I think yeah you can't get me to do it
then I try dude because you're gonna go
over and then you're gonna make those
people wait outside at the Comedy Store
for 30 minutes I don't want to get them
like that I go to a comedy club and they
go run late because I ran late that's
something but if they run late because
the store for this the staff can't cover
it I don't want my people waiting
outside especially now especially now
with this [ __ ] virus so Sam it's a
real pleasure dude I love you Joey Diaz
I appreciate me I'm sorry if I weirded
everybody out the COBE [ __ ] out oh no
hey listen man it's what you [ __ ] do
yeah your pocket is in the top 14 yeah
all right yeah whatever you're doing is
work and God blessed you with two little
[ __ ] girls beautiful I love it slowed
you down which you need to be slow three
and what comedians if there's somebody
who I respect it's you we've been at
that store since we were young kids you
know kids kids kids we're not the place
I do it and we didn't realize how good
we had we didn't realize it and now
we're down there were men and we realize
how good we have it and we act like
gentlemen
yeah real gentleman so it's a real
pleasure man Thank You Now for a word
from our sponsors all right
thanks Sam I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you guys for listening on
this beautiful ones that he 18th I'm
sorry about the situation but it is what
it is you want the dates I don't have
them like I told you Monday refund
everything we don't know what's going on
but let me give a shout out to our
sponsors first off zip recruiter listen
that taking bold steps to attract new
talent by racing wages and increase in
benefits and even that's not working
hiring is getting hard but if you have a
difficult role to fill no matter what
your industry is hire that person with
zip recruiter and now you can try zip
recruiter for free free free free at
cibecue lucam slash church that's zip
recruit accom slash shirts zip recruiter
send your job to over a hundred of the
web's leading job sites but they don't
stop there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience for your job and then they
actively invite them to apply you can
even add screening questions to your job
listing so you can filter out the
candidates and focus on the best ones
zip recruit is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day where you're gonna find
that action at nowhere and right now
tricep recruiter for free the church
family can go to zip recruited comma
slash church that's zip recruited calm
slash Church zip recruiter the smartest
way to hire I want to thank zip
recruiter I want to thank CBD Lyon
I want to thank on it I want to thank
Lee I want to thank Sam Tripoli but most
importantly I want Thank You savages for
listening five on my back I'm sorry
you're going through what you're going
through a couple more days seven more
days of quarantine and you'll be honest
we'll be back Monday morning tip-top
Magoo ready to go have a blessed week
may God bless you guys stay healthy and
I'll be on Twitter messing around with
you guys so
hook me up I love you guys have a great
weekend stay black